salut aujourd'hui pour ce jour des
astuces on va apprendre à gagner un peu
d'argent enfin une date puisqu'elle est
bien tous les mercredis depuis ce 1er
janvier je vous donne une astuce en
rapport avec le mentaliste pour faire
quelque chose qui en dehors du
mentalisme il l'été approchant je me
suis regardé dans analytics quelle est
la plus grande tranche d'âge qui regarde
mes vidéos on va dire grosso modo entre
18 et 35 ans j'ai additionner cette
donnée au fait qu'on allait bientôt être
l'été et que beaucoup d'entre vous allez
sûrement travaillé dans la restauration
comme serveur tu le job qu'on fait le
plus facilement preuve en est que j'ai
fait ce job moi aussi c'est pourquoi je
vais vous livrer mes cinq meilleures
astuces pour avoir des pourboires la
première astuce consiste à faire
travailler votre mémoire ça tombe bien
j'ai fait une playlist sur la mémoire
vous devriez y trouver à l'intérieur des
astuces qui vont vous permettre de
retenir plus facilement qui prend pas en
fonction de la position de la table
qu'éviter de noter avec un carnet mais
retenez plutôt qui prend quoi
et juste avant de quitter la table après
la prise de la commande répété toute la
commande entièrement en désignant les
personnes ça va instaurer une vraie
relation de confiance entre les gens qui
viennent de commander et vous puisque
vous avez retenu
vous êtes capable de le répéter donc ils
sont complètement rassuré et vous avez
redésigné qui prenait quoi ça va marquer
un peu plus la table qu'une prise de
commande au bloc notes la table où
mangent les clients c'est une espèce de
but une fois on avait parlé ensemble de
la bulle individuelles et de cette bulle
devient collective qu'on réunit un
groupe un endroit quand vous prenez une
commande ou quand vous servez ou quand
vous desservez vous percer cette bulle
mais c'est tout à fait admis puisque
c'est votre fonction mais comme vous
percer la bulle
je vous recommande d'identifier
rapidement qui est le leader de la table
c'est la personne qui rit le plus fort
c'est la personne qui en général fait
des blagues vous taquine et c'est aussi
la personne qui commande le vin ou qui
prend les grandes décisions à table et
bien c'est pas forcément cette personne
qui va vous mettre le pourboire mais
c'est la personne qui pourrait empêcher
les autres de mettre un pourboire en dix
ans bah non c'est pas la peine donc il
faut vous la mettre dans votre poche
pour ça c'est très simple il suffit de
l'identifier de pas trop en faire non
plus il suffit juste d'une petite mise
en avant d'une flatterie bien placé pour
se mettre cette personne là dans la
poche
il faut que ce soit fait intelligemment
c'est à dire ne flattent est pas quelque
chose qui n'existe pas mais trouver
quelque chose d'appréciable chez la
personne dans sa manière de vous parler
ou dans sa manière d'être ou dans ce que
cette personne l'a choisi mais encore
une fois sans trop en faire la troisième
astuce est toute simple elle vient de la
première quand vous allez à mener les
plats ne demandez pas pour qui c'est
mais tu es directement aux bonnes
personnes puisque vous aurez retenue en
prenant la commande vous aurez fait ce
petit effort mental temporaire
vous serez capable de donner les plats
sans me demander qui avait pris quoi je
vous assure que dans votre relation avec
la table ça vous fait marquer encore une
fois beaucoup de points 4e as tu sais
quand on vous demande la note vous allez
ramené la note ça c'est tout à fait
normal mais j'ai un vrai truc qui va
mettre un grand coup d'accélérateur sur
le fait que vous allez avoir un bon
pourboire
vous allez préparer à l'avance chez vous
des petits cartons alors ça peut être
sur des cartes de visite planche ça peut
être dos des cartes de visite du
resteront si le restaurant à des cartes
avec un double ans et même d'ailleurs ce
qui est le mieux pour le faire vous
allez donc mettre avec la note un petit
mot de votre part qui va inclure votre
prénom et le fait de remercier la table
ça peut être simplement j'espère que
vous avez passé un bon et agréable repas
à bientôt votre serveur fabien si vous
ne vous appelez pas fabien mettez votre
prénom
c'est mieux et avec cette petite carte
avec ce petit môme était aussi à ou de
bonbons les bonbons c'est la vie les
bonbons ses larmes ultime
si le restaurant ne fournit pas de
bonbons gratuit vous allez acheter des
gros sacs de bonbons a pas très cher et
vous en mettez juste un ou deux c'est
une attention qui fait plaisir qui vous
rendra vous sympathique puisque c'est
vous qui allez donner ça y'a un
restaurant j'ai travaillé il n'y avait
pas les cartes de visite n'y avait pas
les bonbons n'y avait rien on mettait la
note comme ça en vrac sur la table donc
moi je prenais une sous tasse je m'étais
la note le petit mot que j'avais prévu
les deux petits bon moi je posais ça sur
la table
vous êtes en train de générer le tunnel
idéal pour avoir pour bois d'ailleurs
dans ces cas là quand vous n'avez pas de
pourvoir c'est bien souvent parce que
les gens n'ont pas de mots n'est tout
simplement et c'est là que la cinquième
astuces arrive
si quelqu'un vous paye avec un billet de
20 euros ne rendait jamais la monnaie
sous forme de billet si par exemple vous
devez rendre 10 euros et 20 centimes ne
m'étais pas un billet 10 et 20 centimes
était un billet de 5 2 pièces de 2 une
pièce de 1 et 20 centimes vous devez
créer la monnaie qu'on sera susceptible
de vous laisser vraiment à chaque fois
que j'ai fait ça même si je devais
rendre 21 euros je mettais pas un billet
de 20 une pièce de un je mettais un
billet 10 un billet de 5 et 3 fois 2
euros ce qui fait qu'à chaque fois on
line ou deux pièces au serveur et avec
tout ça vous allez voir votre taux de
pourboire augmenté j'espère que toutes
ses astuces vont vous servir cet été ou
dans le cours de l'année ou peut-être
même juste là actuellement ou dans
quelques années mais c'est du testée et
éprouvée par mois est un mentaliste en
serveur je peux dire que ça réfléchit à
tout j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à le faire
savoir en laissant en guise de pourboire
un petit pouce en l'air vous pouvez
également commenter la vidéo puisque je
vis vraiment tous vos commandes
car chaque jour un grand merci également
à tous ceux et celles qui font les sous
titres qui écrivent les sous titres pour
les vidéos c'est un grand travail que
vous faites pour que les malentendants
puissent accéder aux vidéos
merci beaucoup si vous regardez une fois
que j'ai validé les sous titres
maintenant dans le descriptif de la
vidéo on voit vos noms tout en bas pour
vous mettre en avant parce que c'était
bien normal et abonnez-vous bien sûr
puisque le mental bugs et une vidéo par
jour pendant un an donc rendez vous
demain à 17 heures ciao